we're so what we should get the spelling
bee started yeah well I don't I don't
know you know you've met a aleena our
intern before right the the BJ Queen's
the BJ allegedly today's our last day
she's pretty good but uh bill Tetley
somebody called in his built at layer
Lee ER and she wrote bill cut Lee yeah
reminded us that she has had and I I
don't see the phone screen I don't know
if Jim's noticed it but I know the guys
get back have noticed that she has
pretty pretty substantial spelling
issues is that is that fair alene I mean
you're smart woman no you do I see I see
but you're just not a strong spelling no
no no the guys noticed that I don't know
if they let you know that they noticed
that nice when they do they're like
Alina stop [ __ ] out I don't notice it
was your spelling I thought you couldn't
hear oh I can't either
okay I ask them again and then they tell
me and then like Bill and they'll say
okay then they come on here and then
they like that's not what I said
but I double check with that you know I
triple sometimes but a lot of times it's
also spelling errors yeah yeah so that
limit to that that's it that's a thing -
um Troy is also I noticed you spelled
Jeffrey with a IE I just I almost know I
almost walked off the show why would
every je FF rie Jeffrey with IE at the
end it's never spelled like that that's
the one spelling of Jeffrey that doesn't
exist yeah it's a GE
Oh F yeah yeah that's the thing Jim Jim
Jefferies last name and that even has an
S it's a fake name - yeah right is it
mm-hmm
no that's a real name no he just threw
that in there cuz the JJ it's Jim you
know Wilson or something did cheering no
no but you're the only reason that
that's an IE is because there's an S at
the end camera why s that it doesn't
make sense
you'd have to put a es yeah yes if it's
just Jeffrey nobody's ever nobody's ever
ended Jeffrey with an IE have you seen
that before yeah
no you have he's in a band
by the way speaking of band you know
Troy is performing at The Electric zoo
with his bland band and no Black Caviar
was where I was going with that it was a
name yes yeah black Savio what's that
about what's that named after okay oh
yeah we got it we got on the electric
zoo festival next week oh they're just
huge so where can people get tickets all
our informations on our social media
real Black Caviar
what kind of bandit it it's like house
dance music wow cool yeah all right
right here kind of like electronic raver
music is that right yeah I like club
music you do yeah I like to dance
like Sean Paul I do very much so uh sir
Anthony you came up with this bed yeah I
was keeping a list her whole internship
of all the words that she misspelled
okay that's a real scumbag
Bravo so I'm just gonna run down the
words that she misspelled grenade
committed prisoners this is this you
wanted to smell it oh these are all the
words throughout her internship that she
misspelled relationship four times wrong
one of the ways she spelled it I can't
it's one of the words so I don't she
spelled detector as Decatur I don't know
if she was dyslexic
maybe I watched the episode The Cosby
Show and like when Theo said he had a
really related to that I was like maybe
I do that's not a diagnosis that was
exactly I related to Theo the same kind
of dad and the last word I'm gonna say
is military she butchered mi late-40s
are peas and I'm gonna pass this around
right now and then I'm gonna come back
and I'm gonna give the first word okay
wait
spelling bees get scratched no we don't
write i watch spelling bees alright on
your hand yeah you got it no you got to
do it on your hand no scratch yeah you
just try to in the center so it's like
the National Spelling Bee Oh tres pissed
how can I hold are you 23 all right so
that's the unit the text generation so
every words been spelled for you yeah
they just occur if you spell happy it's
like what emoji what number is that six
that's six yes
yeah no Cheers so you don't think it's
my spell words on my cell phone my
article came in like correct what I
suppose there's no idea what you're
doing friend Johnny's like Ellie and I
literally have to like try to think
about what you say yes like sit there
and think that's way too exploring text
do you have certain words that all wait
you know word or like the word you
always writes out this guy when I hit
the wrong letter like I'll be like so
where are you at all right where our guy
[Laughter]
that's just your texting habits a smart
phone talking to that one so here's I
mean in my mind and you guys can correct
me if I'm wrong but the spelling bee
works that the word is presented to you
you are allowed to ask for part of
speech part of speech you are allowed to
ask for it to be used in a sentence hmm
and then you you have to spell the Lord
I think right am I missing always but
that's actually why we're doing this
yeah because that was actually great I
did this wouldn't be fun
I would Troyes this your wave saying you
want to go first you might recognize
that it will look a certain way to
correct or wrong so writing it out no
you can't right now
no you can't although I mean I don't
know that it would help because there
have been there have been significant
spelling errors yes screen oh yeah you
know you've noticed that too Jeffrey so
the first word you should go first hold
on a second I have an opener Anthony's
got an intro oh I forgot I hit that he
loves this bit
he loves his production are you doing
impressions okay good hello friends this
is Anthony from the Jim Norton and
samory
we would not be doing our job correctly
if we did not point out the shortcomings
of our phone screener and in turn only
hey by the way who wrote the yellow who
wrote this top caller on the who's
answering the phones so we decided to
have today we present to you the first
annual Jim Norton and Sam Roberts you
know where it all went wrong was the day
they started the spelling bee spell that
[ __ ] right B there's no fade-out there's
no anything let's get to it and it you
could have just said like the comedic
the idea that we're doing a spelling bee
at all like that is in and of itself you
could have just said the Jim Norton and
Sam Roberts Spelling Bee when you say
spell that [ __ ] write that [ __ ] right
thing yeah I mean that then you're like
adding a little attitude to it and it
sounds like we're actually taking it
seriously
it takes out some of the irony to it and
it becomes a little more of a hack bit
yeah right am I wrong yes okay any
deficiency right like I don't weigh that
there's no way to not be a hack bit with
spelling bees but sometimes it's just
fun to embarrass people and that's your
purpose here right yeah okay good all
right so the first word is Elena it's
experience Oh experience coming out hot
what would you like any any helper do
you have no experience question she asks
if she needs a sentence or part of
speech yeah and then that's that's it
come on now experience e^x p IE i en si
e that's correct
can we check the judges that is correct
right no it's not I'm sorry so what do
we do now do you spell check or do you
give it to Troy I give it to Troy I'm
gonna give it to Troy I want to see if
Troy can be able to spell
and then I will give the correct
spelling of the word seal boy Troy you
got this permanent aren't you in that
band turkey fish eggs experience yes
exp er ience correct
[Applause]
Derek sounds like [ __ ] yeah well I guess
that's the end of this probably
congratulations your prize comprised a
set of steak knives surprises you're
[ __ ] fired
this time Troy has to go first yes I
like that Troy because otherwise that's
not fair
Troy being fair the word is millenium Oh
Lenny has in Ascension morning
that's exciting look at Troy is he and
he considers his choices I've never seen
anything like this millennium is it
millennium
am i okay start that over
uh millennium mal I n I am is that right
I think that could be I'm going you are
fine nine letters later would you like
to would you like to try to steal yeah I
don't know millennium millennium does
that help guys like as in like
Backstreet Boys album a great album the
picture the poster yes the world is
doing the guys the work don't do that
the word is on the poster millennium
right I ll you a.m. millennium that's a
mountain
that's a hard word but that was whale
hard work that's a couple elves in there
and a few eyes and evening you does the
judge want to put them out of their
misery mi ll e n n I um what am i [ __ ]
Einstein I don't but I would have [ __ ]
up the double ends in millenia exactly
yeah but you wouldn't have I mean I
already got the ELLs the either you but
I would not have got it with two ends I
would have [ __ ] yeah yeah can we hear
it again
trash played millennium Metamucil i
farted you're walking right it's all
right I guess it's time for our next big
word and this time
Elena it goes first yes okay the word is
administrator administrate that's a very
easy that's easy that's what it's not
goods on the list administrator a di M I
am ad i sto are way that back I want to
spell the word alright I want to spell
the boy in the meantime then Troy Troy
you're up what Travis is finding that
thing yes administrator administrator
okay administrator
hey what yeah I guess Mel far too wow
it's pretty good all the way over the
counter thanks man
ad mi n ist are 8000 are that's it go to
the instant replay she's close though
hold on yeah I mean Troy almost wants
that one if we go back to a Elena's
spelling are you gonna write this one
down yes administrator a D I am I am
is Geor wow you threw an extra eye in
there
you wrote Adam in the Duster Adam
investor I think you're a little
dyslexic because you put the I am and I
think that you've seen admin written so
many times that instead of a dmin you
wrote a di MN I think you're a little
dyslexic that's my thoughts the second
time you reverse something and I bet
when you add them ad I am I'm like okay
that's just from seeing admin room yeah
or you love addy Amin all right you're
up you're up
let's you know a little something you
know not tricky prisoner ah prisoner
it's a tough one because you know you
think it's about a certain way and it's
not right
pris IO and yar prison prisoner it's
correct that's correct
prisoner got the oh right I thought you
were home free
I'm like she's got this one prison ear
prisoner is a very easy word how that
you both anyway they smell it if they
saw it spelled out they could see it
Troy are you also in your early 20s 23
Troy you're my job doesn't require
spelling your life requires spelling
well I mean that's what the autocorrect
is for prison here I could get it right
if I could write it out yes with that
now is this a trap one nothing - nothing
- no
all right well then let's have Elena
goes first okay Elina by the way both
the Troy's points have been stolen
points so he's gotten to here it spells
true wrong good point
so let's see if you know but nobody has
actually gotten a word right in their
first in the first attempt Elena the
word is passionately BL ACK oh and a te
ly passionately that sounded correct I
figured you were finished with that one
yeah
but Troy there's no way you would have
gotten that no you would not have gotten
a you got very passionate SS IO na te ly
okay oh you are good for the point for a
leader yeah yes so now it's Troy's turn
right his choice turn troy the word is
better not be over one syllable Pharaoh
oh boy
hmm that's a good one that's a good word
let my people go that's right he is
contemplating right now this is one of
Charlie's Angels eh eh r Oh aah
no gone now good the only tempt the tie
Pharaoh pH a ROH Pharaoh
ha ha pH a ROH Pharaoh spell that one
wrong that's a heartbreaker pH a ra o h
ah Troy which is reversed that was
impressive yeah I would impress I would
have [ __ ] that one up there's two
words left okay oh boy oh boy we're
really getting down on the knee
first liaison that's all right you got
it yeah this is not you got this
whatever where's the McCullen for
liaison I don't remember caller
no you're the liaison between us and the
Down syndrome community this word hasn't
actually been said on the phone before
but it's just a word that any 23 year
old should know how to it's never been
said on the show but it's okay I enough
to know that you know that's not right
no I don't think so it's a weird it's
French word right yeah it's not it's not
that hard we we actually do use it in
language you know Don is the liaison
between us and management right right
I'm gonna spell it the weight like
sounds but I know it's not it a masseuse
is the liaison between you and seamen
okay fair enough yeah no she's there no
she's not the connection between him and
come
she's the conductor she's thinking
doctor well would you like what do you
like the definition no it doesn't mean I
just got the part come on no way that's
25 minutes ago
stop sneaking around in it and trying to
putter me up it's the liaison it's like
that Annabelle doll l ie
a s o n no I think correctly actually
and I do think that you're you have
dyslexia a som Li yes
[Music]
no it's not oh did the judge screw it up
is om Li a is Owen oh yeah oh yeah you
didn't know that no I say oh yeah like
you because I would've got liaison along
too
yeah but you're not the judge of a
spelling bee no I know that but I'm not
as good as I thought all right well this
is Troy if you get this right you get
the win wait is this the last word Ben
it's a two-point word yeah we can make
it a two-point word of course we're
making it a two-point word which means
whoever gets this word which means well
Troy get city wins if Elena gets it she
can win repoint word we're know cuz it's
two to one so if Ali Nate whoever gets
this wins yeah if it's two to one if
choice already ahead yeah but it's a
2-point word which mean if Alena gets it
that's three to two but if it's Troy
gets it then he wins twenty five to one
it's making a hundred point or four to
one right that whoever gets this wins
okay shouldn't we do it Lena first
though since it's really they both say
they both get it they're not gonna both
get it how could we just not say whether
the first person got it right Travis dog
captain up all over the word is
handkerchief oh nice one knot Troy Troy
quantum of Black Caviar not feeling
confident in a sentence if you wipe your
belly off with a handkerchief I would
definitely Indians yeah the Asian kids
in the spelling bee always used their
finger to write out like he's thinking
he's thinking
H a and k ER h a late starter Oh God
remember don't say anything
I'm on the edge of my not caring Haan
keer CH i EF alina same question
hankerchief a j and k yeah okay i'd CH i
EF did anybody get it no ok he's what a
Troy say that was wrong Troy everybody
both forgot the D its handkerchiefs and
Elena for my own amusement can you spell
relationship yeah
Arie Travis tweet
yeah I even we had lost track sometimes
sometimes she just like starts spelling
words it did have a really just sounds
like letters it just relationship RelA
tion shi p yeah hmm something you don't
have with your dad that was a nun that
was a non contest by the way is that the
final score to 2-1 troy wins 2 to 1 how
many how many words there out of nine
words troy got two I would have [ __ ]
up liaison unfair oh yeah a travesty
waiting here back this last spelling to
relationship real real real TN ship you
want to give her did you get it I got a
real TN ship she just threw a tea in
there admin a distraught yeah yeah
stator do you have the many spellings of
the word relationship she spelled it she
spelled it the way she spells it just
like that but sometimes she she heads an
extra I
and that common mistake it's weird and I
was like oh maybe the first time I was
like oh she just rushed it and then has
five times
it's definitely dyslexia because she's
writing it too yeah you're just like
sick oh yeah you get a handicap sticker
on your car yeah I think you can put a
vest on your dog - oh yeah dog - yeah
get on the plane that's that's cool well
thank you all for being upon was that
not great good time that was great that
was great